Спочатку респіратор.
Потім обов’язкове вимірювання температури.
36,6.
Так відбувається перезмінка на 13-й підстанції швидкої допомоги Києва.
Сюди нікого не впустять на ранкову зміну і не випустять з нічної,
якщо термометр покаже підвищену темперу у співробітників підстанції.
З початком пандемії коронавірусу бригади саме цієї київської підстанції
мають забезпечувати евакуацію до лікарень хворих з підозрою на коронавірус.
Інші виклики ці бригади не обслуговують.
Ці протиепідемічні костюми одягаються, коли
особа контактувала вже з достовірно зараженою людиною.
Вдягаються такі панорамні маски, вдягаються такі фільтри. Вони наразі стерильні, запаковані.
З дня оголошення карантину в Україні лікарю Денису Міняйлу та фельдшеру Костянтину Тихоненку
доводиться одягати такі костюми по кілька разів на день.
Саме вони та їхні колеги евакуйовували перших хворих у Києві:
студента, який контактував з померлою на Житомирщині хворою на коронавірус,
та туриста з "Борисполя", у якого коронавірус підтвердили експрес-тестом.
Подорожувальники, які повернулися з-за кордону, та їхні родичі
у перші дні дії карантину були головними пацієнтами Дениса та Костянтина.
Підозр 5-7 разів - десь так виїжджали.
Але конкретно в нас не було підтверджених випадків. Підозри були.
Люди, які поверталися з Франції, літаком з Італії поверталися.
І от сьогодні була дівчинка, яка контактувала з достовірно зараженою людиною.
Зміни Дениса та Костянтина тривають 24 години.
Машина "швидкої" має усе необхідне, аби забезпечити стабільний стан пацієнта
навіть з важким перебігом коронавірусної інфекції.
Ось так виглядає апарат штучної вентиляції легень -
у разі необхідності він стане головним рятівником важкохворого.
Зараз нас зараз на коронавірус, тому будемо одягати протиепідемічні костюми і виїжджати на виклик.
Головне при таких викликах - правильно виконати всі інструкції, аби убезпечити себе від зараження.
Бригада має виїхати в одну з приватних лікарень, куди звернулася пацієнтка похилого віку,
в якої, за даними диспетчерів, є симптоми коронавірусної інфекції.
Машина "швидкої" дістається місця призначення доволі швидко,
адже із запровадженням карантину в Україні затори на дорогах практично зникли.
У принципі вже трохи спрацьовує менталітет у водіїв.
Таких от "лосів" уже немає, які не пропускають нас.
Водіям заборонено виходити з машини "швидкої" та напряму контактувати з лікарями,
якщо ті обслуговують коронавірусний виклик. Лікар та фельдшер мають все робити самі.
Цю пацієнтку везуть до Олександрівськові лікарні,
яку визначено головним пунктом прийому хворих з підозрою на коронавірус.
Іноді вранці тут утворюються черги з машин "швидких".
Але не через велику кількість хворих на коронавірус.
Через заходи епідембезпеки процедура прийому пацієнтів триває довше, ніж раніше.
Пацієнтці Дениса та Костянтина пощастило.
Жінка швидко потрапила до рук інфекціоністів. Коронавірусу в неї не виявили.
Підозра на коронавірус у неї не підтвердилася, ми можемо без обробки авто далі їхати на виклик.
Таких непідтверджених випадків, кажуть лікарі, багато.
Щодня диспетчери "швидкої" Києва отримують по кілька сотень звернень від людей,
які підозрюють у себе коронавірус.
Завдання диспетчерів - якісно відфільтровувати інформацію.
Диспетчери орієнтуються на висновки сімейних лікарів.
Ретельно розпитують пацієнта про його стан.
Якщо симптоми радше нагадують РВІ, пацієнту радять звернутися до служби 1583,
де поради дають кваліфіковані лікарі.
Якщо ситуація серйозніша, то виїжджає швидка.
Якщо у людини вже є температура, задуха
і ускладнення, то ми можемо доставити її в інфекційний стаціонар.
Прийде лікар у костюмі, і перевірить, чи нема пневмонії чи ознак бронхіту ніяких.
Буває часто, що люди просто хочуть, щоб перевірили, дуже багато таких викликів.
Нічна зміна на 13-й підстанції. Диспетчер ще раз звіряє інформацію про виклик із сімейним лікарем.
Звернулася жінка, яка вирішила, що вона контактна особа на коронавірус,
тому що їхала в ліфті з чоловіком з високою температуро, який чхнув.
Ще 5 хвилин розмови, і пацієнтка знімає свій виклик.
Поки випадків, коли коронавірус не підтверджується, більше, ніж навпаки.
Так буде не завжди, кажуть лікарі. Імовірно, ситуація може змінитися вже через тиждень.
Тільки через аеропорт "Бориспіль" за минулий тиждень пройшло понад 20 000 туристів та заробітчан,
які повернулися з-за кордону.
Це люди з першої групи ризику.
Денис Міняйло сподівається, що вони прислухалися до порад лікарів
і сидять вдома на самоізоляції, особливо, якщо є ознаки РВІ.
І що їхні родичі також дотримуються правил карантину і не виходять зайвий раз з дому.
Не треба піддаватися паніці. Це нормально. Це не тільки з цим коронавірусом.
Коли раніше були пандемії грипу, так само мало бути.
Чогось раніше так не робили. А зараз, може, людство одумалося. Не знаю.
Медики поки оцінюють ситуацію з коронавірусом у Києві як "стабільно контрольовану".
У столиці, де мешкає майже чотири мільйони людей, щоденно працюють приблизно 300 машин швидкої.
Поки цього, як вважають у Центрі екстреної медичної допомоги та медицини катастроф Києва, достатньо.
У разі, якщо коронавірус почне швидко поширюватися,
постане питання, де брати додаткові бригади медиків швидкої.
Минулого року через низькі зарплати звідси звільнилося багато молодих фахівців.
Також може виникнути проблема нестачі лікарів у інфекційних відділеннях.
Нині в Києві визначено дві головні лікарні,
куди скеровують хворих з підозрою на коронавірус - Олександрівська та 4-та інфекційна.
До кінця березня київська влада хоче ще підготувати також 8-му лікарню для таких пацієнтів.
Українські лікарі виходять з того, що якщо коронавірус в Україну завезли туристи з-за кордону,
то спалах захворювання проявиться через тиждень-два.
Поки що Київ, як стверджує мер Кличко, є епіцентром захворюваності на коронавірус в Україні.
Але справді критичною ситуація може виявитися в регіонах.
Адже чим далі від Києва, тим гірше оснащення лікарень, швидких і навіть не завжди є
елементарні тести на виявлення коронавірусу.